for the record this is awesome but why
do you guys have a giant Lego set anyway
it is a three-dimensional model of the
place where I was predestined to be
brutally murdered by a twisted future
version of buried man's future but what
a difference a year makes hey everybody
it looks like it's almost time for a
prison break so big twist at the end
totally did not expect them to go
through that fast but I think we all
assumed that berry wasn't gonna be in
prison for that long this season it was
just a question of what kind of twist
they would use to get him out and I do
like the direction they took this it's a
bit of a twist on the Geoff Johns
thinker arc from the comics from the
Wally West era so I'll try to explain
Easter eggs as we go along but you know
really big twist about cecile getting
powers and leading up to big Irish stuff
happening later this season but just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet starting with number 10
how about that savat our explainer
probably the funniest way of explaining
an entire season's worth of plot hey
what do you guys have Legos for what's
this all about IRA sounds like she's
almost practiced that explainer like
she's had to explain to other people
what she's been up to
oh we know well there was a seaville
speedster who was a duplicate of my
husband who was coming for me they even
drop a Simpsons reference and bigan
isn't a word someone should tell iris
that am bigan is a totally Crom youlet
word but number nine obviously one of
the big twists of the episode Cecile
gets mysterious powers and they go
through this long list of things just
crossing off some of the bigger theories
about how this could have happened she
says she wasn't on the bus so she's not
a bus Mehta she didn't get doused with
dark matter when Barry came out of the
Speed Force
it wasn't alien abduction which is
probably something from the dominators
just because there's a last big alien
invasion that we had and then no magic
totem is just a reference to vixen in
zari on legends this season if they
actually did reference the legends a
couple times because the dwarf star
villain uses dwarf star alloy as part of
how he got his powers in Ray Palmer uses
dwarf star alloy in his suit and they
had Palmer tech so there was a lot of
add on comic book stuff crossing over
with this episode and I almost forgot
all the Pokemon turns out cisco has
pokemons on the brain more than we
thought
Bulbasaur because he's the cutest one
why am I thinking about Pokemon at a
time
like this there were some people in my
timeline that took offense at that
they're like there's no way that
Bulbasaur is the cutest one
feel free to argue about that one in the
comments but number eight the actual
explainer for how she got her powers is
is that she had latent Dark Matter stuck
in her brain during the original
particle accelerator explosion in
whatever biological systems became
active during her pregnancy triggered
that to become active so she got her
powers because of the pregnancy but the
baby itself is not a meta that's telling
you what they're not doing so there was
some specific explainer stuff happening
to tell you what's not going to happen
in the future one the baby will not be a
meta it's going to be a girl so a lot of
people were like hey wait a minute
does that mean that it's gonna turn into
coffee shop girl because we don't know
if she's a meta it kind of seems like
she is but just add that to the list of
theories about who she could be although
I still think that she's gonna be
Berry's daughter or his granddaughter I
know a lot of people wanted it to be a
more comic book II twist we still don't
know what they're going to name the girl
but I think they just want to let us
know that no we're not gonna turn this
into another flash Joe already has one
child that has flash powers Wally West
iris will get temporary speed force
powers later this season a third child
to get Speed Force powers would be a
little redundant so it'll be interesting
to find out who this child is but I'm
not expecting any super big twist maybe
a couple comic book Easter eggs though
number seven Barry tries to help
Goldberg get out of prison which sort of
tees up the dwarf star plotline he drops
another Shawshank reference talking
about how hope is the most dangerous
thing in here but eventually does end up
getting him out by the end of the
episode I was kind of hoping that he
would be around later this season for a
big Prison Break brawl but it looks like
they're taking that in a different
direction based on the twist at the end
but for the most part it does seem like
Goldberg ends the episode knowing that
Barry is the flash along with another
big character too but the whole thing
with the Goldberg character about Barry
trying to keep him hopeful keep him
optimistic the movie ending that you
don't usually think that you would get I
got to marry my sweetheart iris I got
the movie ending that's him maintaining
his sense of optimism while he's in
prison even though he gets bummed out
that's part of what makes Barry Allen
the flash is just his sense of
positivity in the face of stuff like
this so number seven entered dwarf star
if you guys didn't know who he is he's a
big comic book character I talked about
him a little during the trailer video I
did earlier but in the comics he uses a
mechanical belt to shrink stuff down the
way they explain him as one of the bus
metas in this episode is that he stole
dwarf star tech and then got doused
while he was on the bus so the
combination of dark matter with the
dwarf star alloy just gave him the
metahuman ability to shrink stuff down
and bring it back up to normal size just
like during the ant-man trailer they
actually used a couple of twists that we
saw during that like when they threw the
giant Hello Kitty PEZ dispenser
he's throwing big stuff at them at the
end of the episode but talk about
coincidence number six he shrinks the
entire building down which is supposed
to be metahuman proof it was all done
for that big twist like oh this has anti
speedster cameras it has all kinds of
technology to keep metas out and then
boom just shrinks it right down the only
thing that would have made that funnier
is if he would have popped a handle out
the top just like Hank Pym did during
that ant-man the wasp trailer probably
one of the funniest twists though behind
his character is is that he has this
great power but he's just using it to
collection like he's just shrinking
things down that he really wants only
it's the real thing it just miniaturized
versions remember however once in a
while the flash TV show will take shots
at arrow like iris joking about what
happened during their wedding during the
crossover how they kind of stole their
thunder here the new mayor talks about
how their crime rate is crazy high but
it's still not quite as high is the
crime rate of Star City so just another
Digga arrow I'm sure Stephen Amell will
find some way to get them back in a
future episode but number five they get
shrunk down Honey I Shrunk the Kids
style they mostly use it for comedy but
like I said they did that big sabotage
joke they have the lego set we haven't
seen that since season three elongated
man wasn't here for any of that stuff so
he doesn't know what they did last year
but Harrison wells drops a Doctor Who
reference when he talks about reversing
the polarity when it backfires we also
learned Harrison wells is really upset
with himself we learned gorilla
prison-like gorilla City from last year
is actually much worse than normal
prison they throw their poop at you
number four berry versus the prison
warden it seemed like they were setting
him up is it
tagging is for the back half of the
season potentially for season five
because the warden is a big comic book
character so it makes sense that he has
this philosophy that all the people in
iron Heights are monsters Barry is like
the antithesis of that like he believes
in the good and everyone so it makes
sense that they would logically set him
up as an antagonist and Barry would
start looking through all the different
files of the prisoners eventually maybe
trying to help them out in a future
season he's kind of busy this season
with thinker stuff so maybe they'll loop
back around but number three the whole
big twist at the end of the episode is
that the prison warden catches him on
camera being the flash and is now
selling metahumans to the blacksmith
who's coming back and I guess next
week's episode and it still doesn't seem
to have any connection with what Deveaux
is doing even though team flash
references that so the really big thing
about this you have to think about this
long term if the prison warden who's a
relatively big figure in local law
enforcement knows that Barry is the
flash and he really hates Barry is he
going to keep his secret after this
episode is done or after whatever art
he's part of because this seems like too
big of a risk during season five season
six whatever going forward like enemies
knowing who the flash is suspense
trouble for everybody in general so
unless they're gonna wipe his mind at
the end of the season it seems like
they're setting the warden up to die
because he seems pretty evil right now
way more evil than the comic book
version of itself but you guys can let
me know in the comments do you think the
prison warden survives to next season
continuing to know that Barry Allen is
the flash number two team flash
considers what's going on with Davos
plan does he want them all in prison
does he want all the things that just
happened to happen like how is he moving
chess pieces around the board because
when the prison warden calls blacksmith
to sell another metahuman it has nothing
to do with the thinker it's almost like
this small ecosystem within the
thinker's plan because he has all those
metahumans that are locked up - and it
sounds like there's a prison break
coming next week so it sounds like we
were building towards that anyway but
this might be how all those bust metas
wind up getting out like he rounds them
up they all get captured he wants them
to get thrown in prison so that they're
all in the same place but then the
events of next week's episode or the
episode after that happened and they use
that to
in there all their together he doesn't
have to go hunt them down one at a time
anymore
but just remember that they hung up
eight photos so we're down to four I
didn't think that there were that many I
was trying to remember all the ones that
they caught so far but obviously number
one big twist is his cecile ends the
episode still having her powers and
Caitlin said that they should go away
when she gives birth so I'm wondering
how far off that's going to be and
whether or not there'll be some other
twist with those because if iris is
supposed to get Speed Force powers or
you know manifest them fully like we all
think that she was manifesting them in
this moment here so it's already begun
with her it just hasn't developed to the
point that Cecile's powers have how many
episodes will iris actually have those
powers because it seems like she's only
gonna be in the costume for episode 16
so what might end up happening is is
episode 15 in episode 17 after that
there's still like some aftershocks
going on but she slowly ramps up and
starts doing funnier and funnier things
until they actually realized what's
going on in episode 16 but if you were a
little confused about the reasoning and
the logic behind cecile getting powers
how those powers work in what it means
for the future of the baby or what it
doesn't mean like doesn't mean that it's
gonna be Daniel West all you need to
take away from this is that within the
world of the flash where all these metas
are running around you have all this
dark matter giving people powers
pregnant women who were around during
the original blast and have some sort of
residual dark matter in their bodies can
get powers from pregnancy so I think
we're all probably an agreement now and
hopefully you understood after this
episode that they're just leading up
into that like oh my god how do I have
powers oh maybe it's because you're
pregnant
like Cecile was but if there were any
other Easter eggs in the episode that
you guys spotted that I didn't mention
in the video just write them below in
the comments I did talk about some of
the Goldberg wrestling Easter eggs
during my trailer video but he won a
couple titles those were in the numbers
when they flashed his bio up on the
screen there's a new round of that blast
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and share the
video using those tools on the watch
page congratulations to the winner from
that last trailer video I did young
adapt
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here to
rewatch that ant-man in the wasp trailer
and click here for my video on that
mystery girl thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight